thank you so much Vasilis and thank you
so much for organizers for inviting me
I'm really honored to to give this
lecture yeah so my talk today is going
to be
it's called average-case complexity
through a lens of interactive puzzles
and it's really going to be about
combination of cryptography and
complexity and the interplay between the
two so let me start from the beginning
before jumping into average-case
complexity let's start off with the most
foundational and important open problem
in computer science and maybe even in
mathematics today which is a P versus NP
problem which roughly speaking can be
summarized as follow is it the case that
if a solution sub problem can be
efficiently verified can we also then
efficiently find the solution it's a
little bit more precisely the class of
problems and P is defined as a set of
problems for which solutions also called
witnesses can be efficiently verified
and by efficiently verified we mean they
can be verified in polynomial time it's
a little bit more precisely we said a
language l is an NP if there exists some
Palumbi 'l relation such that this an
instance is in a language if and only if
there exists some witness that certifies
that this instance is in the language
and so whenever some instance is true
whenever some instance is a language I
can therefore provide a witness W that
you can efficiently verify by running
this parlament a verifier and then there
the question of whether P equals NP
boils down to saying is it the case that
all languages in NP can be efficiently
decided in polynomial time so just very
briefly give you some examples of MP
problems perhaps the most common known
one is boolean satisfiability given some
boolean formula it does exist a
satisfying assignment
another very famous problem is that of
Gref 3-coloring
and let's actually restrict to a planar
graphs I'm giving you a planar graph so
a graph that can be drawn without any
any edges intersecting or any edges
crossing and the question now is can I
color this graph so that any two nodes
that have an edge between them have
different colors and the graph 3
coloring problem refers to the question
of whether it's possible to color this
graph with just three colors right so
these problems are all in in NP can
efficiently verify whether you have a
solution if I give you a coloring can
check that any two nodes that are
connected with an edge have different
colors and you can check that it uses
less than three colors or at most three
colors and it turns out they're also
np-complete so they're as hard as any
other problem NP now the P versus NP
problem might actually not be the main
question we're interested in in practice
right it could be a case that NP is hard
on the worst case meaning that it is
actually hard for every algorithm tries
to decide some NP problem there exist
some instances of it it fails but it
could be the case that those instances
actually never really arise in practice
so practice what we care about is
whether we end up with instances that
turned out to be hard
all right and the area of average-case
complexity trust exactly address this
problem
so rather than looking at trying to
solve this and NP problems in in the
worst case we would have looked at we
consider some kind of sampler samples
instances and we're wondering whether it
is the case that were example instances
from some efficiently sample
distribution this problem still is hard
to to solve
okay and it could just be the cases in
real life it is the case that the
instances we encounter or just turned
out to be easy all right so a little bit
more precisely we just going to say that
the language is hard on the average or
average case hard if there exists some
probabilistic polynomial-time sampling
algorithm sort of some efficient
sampling algorithm it runs in polynomial
time but has access to run - so this
sampler D sample some instances these
instances a large fraction of them
should be in the language so let's say
for simplicity that two-thirds of the
instances are in the language and I say
that this language is hot an average if
it is the case that even though many
instances are in the language no prob
listing polymer time algorithm can
actually turns out to find a witness
when our sample instances from this
distribution okay doesn't make sense so
we have some sampler he sampled some
instances and I'm calling this this
problem hardened average if it is the
case that no algorithm no efficient
probablistic Palomita algorithm will be
able to find witnesses through sample
instances with probability 1/3 okay so
this is one particular definition of
hardened average it's actually not the
original definition and that Levin
proposed so in this particular
definition we're talking about the task
of finding a witness in in Levin's
original definition he instead consider
a decisional problem where the task was
instead to decide whether an instance is
in the language or not from my purposes
I'm going to stick to this search
problem wherever the question is to find
the witness and it turns out that this
is actually without loss of generality
this various different notions of
hardened average for NP have been
studied for a long time
and now we understand that they're all
actually essentially equivalent so in
particular the question of finding a
witness first to deciding a language
makes no difference and the definitions
are equivalent so for my purpose it's
going to be just easier to talk about
this type of search problems all right
so let me present this definition yet
the latter time but using a slightly
different language so syntactic it's
actually gonna be exactly the same it's
just using a slightly different language
so I'm going to consider it this kind of
problem scenario as a game between some
challengers see and some attacker a this
challenge is C needs to be polynomial
time and what he does first is his
samples and instant x then the goal of
attacker is to find some witness and the
Challenger would eventually accept if
indeed the attacker managed to find a
witness such that this relation the
witness and peer relation accepted and
for this language to be hard on average
we require two conditions the first one
is a non-trivial T condition which is
that whenever C samples this X with
probability at least to search the
instance is indeed in language and
therefore has a witness and the hardest
condition just rephrase what we said
before that doesn't exist a polynomial
time attacker that managed to convince
the Challenger with probability greater
than 1/3 that make sense okay so this
it's kind of a game based way of
defining what it means for language to
be hardened average now it's clearly
very very widely believed that NP is hot
on average it's kind of a very minimal
assumption to be making in complexity
theory yet somewhat surprisingly it is
the case that even when we have this
empty complete problem or it turns out
that many of them actually can be
efficiently solved on many distributions
of interest all right so there are all
these heuristics that seem to do pretty
well
so the question I'd like to address in
this talk is trying to understand what
may
an MP problem hot on average like order
some characteristics of the problem that
makes it hot on average okay in
particular could it be the case that
there are some natural subclasses of
problems that make it easy okay in
particular is it the case that maybe I
can restrict the class of problems in
some natural way or maybe restrict the
class of distributions in such a way
that makes the problem easier right and
that would be a way to understand where
this hardness stems from and indeed
there have been these subclasses of MP
and that have been defined and studied
and some of them extremely natural okay
and some of them were actually as old as
average-case complexity
so the first thing I would like to talk
about is something called total function
and P or TF and P so TF MP is a subset
of NP problems where it is the case that
actually every instance has a witness
okay and I'm going to go over this in a
lot more detail next few slides so this
is a way to restrict the class of NP
languages because right now in
districting it to two problems where
every instance has a has a solution but
I can also restrict the distribution
okay so not only restricted and the
language necessarily but now instead
let's consider some more natural
distributions and in fact the notion of
a one-in function that's commonly used
in cryptography can be viewed as
equivalent to consider a heart of
average language in NP were accosted a
very restricted distribution in
particular distributions were not only
the Challenger is sampling an instance
but also one where the Challenger is
sampling an instance together with a
witness so it could have any case that
for those type of distributions the
problem becomes easier right so let me
in fact go over both these two things in
more detail and then
we'll take it from there okay so let's
start with EFMP so TF MP as I mentioned
is the class of languages in NP where is
the case that in fact every instance is
true and every instance has a witness
right so a language isn't even people is
the case that for every X actually
exists a witnessed that makes it
satisfied but it could still be hard to
find this witness right so we're
restricting to this type of languages
where everything is true
everything has a witness but it could
still be the case that it's still hard
to find it and indeed in fact we do
believe that if MP is hot on average
tour at least the TPP has instances
through a heart an average before I give
you some examples of problems in TFM B
let me just go over to MP using this
game based worldview instead so TF MP
well remember the previous way we looked
at average case MP we have this
challenge you each sample some instance
and then you're supposed to respond with
a witness and we had these two
conditions non-trivial it in hardness
and travolta said that with probability
at least two-thirds the challenge is to
sample instance it's true okay right now
we can get rid of this thing because
restricting to languages where every
instance is true and so that's what the
totality condition says that in fact for
every X there always exists some witness
yeah all right so now you consider a
scenario where he sampled some X for
every extra exists a witness and the
task is for you to find it here it seems
to make the problem a lot easier right
all right let me give you some examples
of things in EFMP so one very nice
example which is a closed variant of
graph three coloring is graph for
coloring okay so the graph for coloring
always exactly as before
is a planar graph and the question is
can color it in four colors right this
is a problem that's been actually
studied for a long time and in 1852
Frances Guthrie conjectured in fact the
answer is always yes for every planar
graph you can invite color it with four
color and that was actually first proven
in 1976 so the answer actually is yes so
for every paragraph there always is a
for coloring but the question is how do
you find it okay so that's one nice
curious problem as far as I know it
doesn't really have any particular
practical applications because at least
according to Wikipedia most real life
maps can actually be done in three
colors anyway so it's but it's it's cool
that's you know we tweaked it a little
bit and now you have a probability of MP
so here is something that's a little bit
more practical in today's world so
machine learning okay
one of the key things in machine
learning today is a method called a
gradient descent which is a particular
instance of what's referred to as local
search so local search you can kind of
abstract the problem local searches as
follows I'm gonna give you three
algorithms one init algorithm that
starts by giving you some initial
solution then you have a neighbor
algorithm that given some initial
solution gives you a set of neighboring
solutions and then you also have a cost
function so all these things are polar
melton computable Paolo meal size
circuits I'm giving you and your goal is
to find a local minimum so there is some
kind of some instance X such that for
every neighbor the cost is no smaller
okay so
why does something like this always have
a solution well as the picture there
suggests let's say we start there then
you look at all your neighbors and you
find one that is take this one the one
that has a smallest cost and then you go
there okay from there you take one has a
smallest cost and so on and so forth and
eventually you have to come top - no
that doesn't have any neighbors with
smaller costs because otherwise you know
you run out of different costs so local
search clearly is is a very useful thing
and here we guaranteed that a solution
always exists okay let me move on to
another very famous instance of a set of
problems in in TF and P which is the
Nash equilibrium problem so I'm giving
you a game and give you a description of
a game and the task is for you to find a
Nash equilibrium I'm not really going to
define it what a Nash equilibrium is but
a very celebrated result by John Nash
from 1951 states that in fact every
finite game has a Nash equilibrium okay
but the question is how do we find it
and this is actually one of the today
when a most celebrated problems in EFMP
it turns out that the Nash equilibrium
problem is complete for a subclass of
the key called Peapod and and people are
still actively working on trying to
prove hardness of people on their
various cryptographic assumptions
alright so what I hope to convey it so
far is that even though we're
restricting the set of languages to
those where every instance is guaranteed
to have a solution we're still
considering a very natural class of
problems and affect many things of
interest full interesting and for many
of them we believe them to be hard so an
important open problem is is it the case
that these problems in EFMP
are actually as hard as generality
problems
average so in particular is it the case
that if NP is hotter than average then T
if NP is also hot on average right or
another way of stating it is it easier
to solve problems when you're guaranteed
that they have a solution so so there is
evidence both falling against okay so
evidence against a is in fact graph for
coloring not long after they managed to
prove that every planar graph is for
color burg turned out that they also
managed to get efficient algorithms okay
and they were maybe not very efficient
first it became even more efficient
later so that thing can be done very can
be done efficiently and somewhat
intuitive it seems like look if you know
there a theorem has a solution has a
proof then it seems easier to find it
right you know that you're not just
going down the wrong path you know that
there exists the proof you're gonna work
harder and maybe find some I don't know
right just intuitive it seems should be
easier now evidence for this
implications we also have that in fact
only the original paper by megiddo and
perimeter show that if NP is if MP is
hard then it's also hard to find kind of
a canonical solution for T of MP problem
so if there exists a particular type of
inferences you look at this local search
issue if your goal is to find a
particular solution in that case it
becomes hard but that's not really what
we're after all right would like to just
the considered problem of finding some
solution and there were some very nice
recent programs progress two years ago
where who but check now or and
huh I'm Blanca prove the implication
they prove this implication under some
complexity conjecture in particular some
kind of the randomization conjecture
I'm not going to exact with
determination codes actuaries but it's
something saying that exponential time
computations cannot be significantly
sped up by by circuits that have access
to something called sigma2 gates
it's add randomization conjecture and
under that assumption this can be proven
okay it's a great question we don't know
okay in fact that's going to be the next
thing I'm going to talk about is this
problem of one-way functions okay but
indeed if one can soul your problem and
that would be a major breakthrough and
I'll get that shortly all right so now
the second class of restriction we can
look at is instead of a restricted class
of MP problems we're going to restrict
the class of distributions okay so in
fact one of the original motivations for
studying average-case complexity it came
actually from cryptography ok and any
cryptography it's not so usually not
enough to just say there exists some
distribution that's that's hard on
average but we're also required to be
possible that to sample these instances
that are hard together with a solution
right so let's look at well okay so with
a picture you know maybe it is the cases
where the business is they look like
this they're very hard and when I
my son to draw a labyrinth with a
solution then this is what he came up
with as you see it's like you know which
one I come up with an instance with a
solution it becomes much easier to solve
intuitively all right so let's rephrase
this thing again as this game based
using this game based view so I have not
what Challenger the Challenger is going
to run this sampler D and this sampler
is going to output an instance X and the
witness okay that's the total sampler
and we require now that in fact this
sample needs to always output a correct
witness right so it's always sample sum
X and a witness then the challenge it
doesn't actually output this witness it
just has it there and it just outputs
the instance X and now your job is to
find a witness okay so for reasons they
can become clear
pretty soon it's going to be important
for me to just write down the randomness
of this theory of this sampler so this
sampler takes some some random s or as
input and outputs this X and W okay so
now this non-trivial condition is
replaced by saying the sampler
take some some randomness output some X
and W that is where the W is a correct
witness and we now have the same
hardness condition before that no
attacker should be able to no problem at
the mataki should be able to recover the
witness now let me point out that this
somewhat looks similar in some ways to T
and P and it's actually indeed quite
related but different this was already
pointed out in the original paper by
Maggie debris material so note here that
sampler the sampler here he always picks
instances toward true right because he
knows the witness to them he needs to
pick an instance and a witness so the
instance X
is always true also but it's not the
case that every X necessarily has a
witness right so even though it is the
case that it's always picking instances
are true
this isn't this does not give me this is
not a problem T of MP because not the
case necessarily the language that for
the language advocated every X has a
witness okay so I'm agin imper pyramid
to refer to these type of problems as
promised if and P problems are not
exactly differently okay so this notion
of sampling when a witness has the only
mention is very very close related to
the notion of a one in function that's a
really key in cryptography so let me
define the notion where money function
and then we'll see why this is actually
exactly the same thing as the notion of
hot and average when I simply with a
witness so a one-way function is a
function f that can be efficiently
computers but that you have the
appropriate ought to invert it so let's
look at it as this game so now the
Challenger is sample some random or he
computes the function to get some output
Y and the attackers job is to find some
preimage or prime such that F of R prime
equals to Y doesn't necessarily exactly
the same one just needs to find some
preimage and the hardness condition here
is that no attacker should be be able to
win in this game with probability again
greater than 1/3 so in other words no
attack in no efficient attacker can
invert this and this function turns out
that is actually exactly equivalent to
to the previous definition the existence
of what a function is equivalent to the
existence of an empty language where
it's we can sample for the distribution
samples an instance with a witness and
well one direction is trivially if I
have a one in function then clearly this
gives rise to a distribution on
something why why is the instance in
your job is to find a witness a
pre-image right so
when we function clearly gets tries to
turn instance where I'm sampling an
instance with a witness but the other
direction is also very easy to see so if
I have this type of languages hot on
average with respect the distribution as
sample instance with a witness then I
can view the distribution D will be
sampling algorithm for the distribution
as a one-way function also so to do that
would be useful to just decomposed into
two parts so first this D and let's Dion
be the first output of D and let D to be
the second output in the witness in that
case I claim that this D 1 actually is a
1 a function because if it wasn't if it
was a case that given X you could
recover and find the randomness or the
clearly we can go back to all and then
recompute W and and then you're done
okay
so really what we functions the
existence of when a function is really
exactly the same thing as the existence
the hot an average language where we're
saying it's hard to sample hard to find
witnesses to instances they're been
sampled together with a witness now in
crypto this definition is somewhat weak
because we're just saying it's hard to
find that pre match with probability
greater than 1/3 income photographic
applications you really want it to be
the probability for inverting should be
much smaller and indeed this difference
is not really substantial you can always
unplug Ardis using what's called llaves
order simplification theorem there's
also a minor issue regarding infinity
offer vs.
almost everywhere let me just ignore it
you can look for in the paper for more
details so one way functions are one of
the most crucial cryptographic
primitives in fact I would say it's
easily the most important today and most
central cryptography primitive they are
we have lots of different candidate
constructions of money function so and
we have you know really believe that
money functions exist and in fact we
really hope they do because the
equivalent to to all these other
cryptographic primitives that we care
about like encryption schemes pseudonym
generators surround functions digital
signatures commitments basically you
know most of the key cryptographic
primitive are equivalent to the
existence of only functions okay so that
gives gives rise to the second open
problem which dates back to this
original work by different men from the
1976 is in a case that we can based
existence of on a function on some kind
of a hardness of NP in particular could
we say that if MP is hot on average we
can also get a construction of one a
function all right this would be one of
the you know dream problems in
cryptography to base one a functions an
MP and the hot on average and another
way of saying it is the case that
solving problems there are sample with a
solution is that easier than just
solving
random problems okay so you know
evidence against well one evidence is
that intuitively again like you know
Isaac's my son's puzzle here is seem
clearly easier to solve than that thing
I got real Internet right and indeed the
various ways you can formalize this
thing using some kind of notions of
black post-separation reverse different
black book separations that kind of
indicate that it would be hard to prove
such an implication and in fact draw a
black book separations also between EFMP
and an average case hardness vampy also
I should mention that we also have some
everyone
for in a similar style to what was done
before by the result of a buncha guitar
and there are these very nice results
come back cooler to the 90s showing that
if we have something called zero
knowledge for NP then it is the case
that vamp is on average then we also
have one a function okay and you can
also base it on indistinguishable
confiscation Potter is two things are
kind of orthogonal to empty being
hardened averaging particular MP is
equal to p0 knowledge for MP exists
trivially so so we have some some
assumptions that are believable under
which this implication is true okay so
this takes me to the main results that I
like to talk about today or at least
give some intuition about which is a
result we are not able to solve either
of these problems okay we would love to
that would be awesome and I hope
somebody will one day but what we can
say is that the answer to at least one
of them is yes okay it could be that
both or yes I hope so
okay but right now at least for one of
them dancers yes in particular the
theorem that we proved is it if and
posada average then that implies either
Latif in peace harden average or that
one a functions exist okay so another
way of stating this is in the language
of integration simple glad Shaw consider
various different possible worlds matter
and one of them was called pestle and
pestilent according to him was the worst
of all possible worlds at least in
complexity theory okay and so personal
is a world where NP is hot on average so
meaning that if we would like to solve
this MP problems in real life we really
need to cannot expect of general-purpose
algorithms they're going to do well and
in general it's gonna be hard all right
but one way functions don't exist so we
don't even we don't have crypt
Murphy right so algorithms are not very
powerful yet we don't have cryptography
rights it's a very pessimistic world for
us yeah so one way to interpret our
result is that pestilent is actually
even worse than what we previously
believed because not only NP is hard in
pestilent but also TMP is hot until
passing that all right so in what
remains I'm going to try to give you a
proof overview and more than overview
this going to give you some kind of
flavor of and approach it we're
proposing and this approach is to study
these problems not directly but in fact
studying a different object altogether
but hopefully the language I've been
using so far kind of indicates where I
was going so what we're going to do is
to introduce force a generalization of
average case hardness okay so both T and
P money functions we said that they
could be viewed as special cases of FGS
rcmp but now we're going to instead look
at something more general and that is
going to be something we call an
interactive puzzle so what's an
interactive puzzle well think of it as a
computer game right in a game I don't
just get a single challenge I need to
answer but yeah I get a challenge and I
have to move somewhere than a game toss
this terminal coins and then I have to
move and so and so forth so it's really
an interaction between this Challenger
and the attacker where the Challenger is
tossing some random coins in between
every step
okay so I'll define it more formal
shortly but really think of this as an
interaction challenges sense around
coins sends it to attack attacking is to
send a message then a challenges sensor
and coins attacker responds and so on so
forth now it would be very obvious that
in fact the assumption 10-piece hardened
average is going to turn out to be
equivalent to the existence of a two-run
puzzle let's follow mostly by definition
and it turns out and if you consider a
special class of puzzles with something
we call perfect
and roughly speaking perfect completists
will say that the attacker can always
win in this game or sorry
well there is it's always possible to
win in this game not the technique in
all ways but it's always possible in
that case those type opposites are going
to give rise to language in TMP that's
hard an average okay so the language of
puzzles allows us to capture already
these familiar content notions and the
main thing we prove is around collapse
theorem for puzzles that's going to say
something like if you give me a seven
run puzzle I can construct a six run
puzzle second collapse runs and for our
purposes so we're going to show is that
if one-way functions don't exist then we
can do a round collapse that in fact
also preserves perfect completeness so
if the original had perfect pizzas and
you won't also have that now am i
wondering where is all of this going it
seems like we're doing something
completely unrelated to what we wanted
to do well it turns out that actually
from the literature interactive proofs
and turns out interactive proofs are
very related to this interactive puzzles
as the name suggests there are some
results that can be kind of potahto
setting and there came interplays saying
that if you give me a two-run puzzle I
can construct a 3-run puzzle has perfect
completeness okay so you can take a tour
and puzzle you construct a 3-run puzzle
with perfect complements and now you can
collapse rounds if one a functions don't
exists so the conclusion is that either
one a functions exist in which case
we're done or it is the case that we can
go from torrent to three-run perfect
complete this and two back to to run
with perfect complete ins which gives me
a hot and heavy language in the FMP
alright so this was very high level let
me now introduce the notion of
interactive puzzle and then go over all
each of these steps a little bit more
detailed sorry thirty puzzle as I only
hinted at considers this interaction
where I have a challenger that says
samples random coins he said picks a
random bit long string
the attacker attack he needs to provide
an answer then he picks another one then
attack a need to provide an answer and
so and so forth and eventually after a
certain number of rounds we're done and
then that the Challenger is going to
apply some Paloma ten computable
algorithm on the transcript to decide
what it's going to accept the reject
[Music]
we're going to go back to our two
conditions from before that we use for
average case holidays vampy the first
one non-trivial t in this context are
going to be saying that there exists
some unbounded attacker that can make
the challenge accept so if you run in
exponential time you can make the
Challenger accept okay so does it means
that you know it is possible to make it
win but the hardest condition is going
to say that a polynomial-time guy cannot
make him win with probability more than
one third okay so I'm taking this notion
this kind of games from before and I'm
generalizing it to minimize the
interaction and we're just generalizing
non trivial until holidays in a natural
way non trivial t just says there exists
some way for an unbonded guy to win it's
just that the in polymer time you cannot
do it so that's what I'm going to call
in 30 posit any questions so there are
two things that worth pointing out so
this is very similar to something called
Arthur Merlin games to find web by Ben
Warren which are equivalent to what's
called public own interactive proofs so
they consider a very similar in fraction
pattern we have verified as samples run
on coins in the proper response and so
on but the difference is that we're now
considering a computational sunless
property right in those kind of proof
system this hardness condition really
was saying that non trivial that didn't
hold it you say there is no attacker
that can win in this interaction can
make the challenge accept
so rather this computation the hardly
condition we have here is in fact very
very similar to the notion of a
computational soundness in the case of
an interactive argument so you can think
of this kind of as an interactive
argument for a empty language in a sense
having a property that you know the
prover can actually do with unbounded
time you can win but no computational
boundary guy can can win now the fact
that these are very similar to
interactive arguments is gonna be a very
good thing for us because there's been a
lot of literature studying interactive
arguments and we can leverage that in
particular these two thirds in one third
or not great we'd like to reduce them
we'd like to get the completeness this
non-trivial T saying that they can win
with probability one minus something
very small and you would like hardness
to say nobody can win with except with
very small negative probability and
indeed you can actually amplify them
using parallel petition parallel
resistance theorems have been
established for public horn interactive
arguments it's using exactly the same
kind of lemmas they're proven their
turns out that defining it with 2/3 1/3
is the same as the funny which is 1
minus negative all right now let's get
to this perfect completeness property
it's probably what you or own expecting
and we say that a puzzle has perfect
completeness
if this non-trivial T condition actually
kind of holds it probability one in a
sense that an unborn attacker can always
make the Challenger accept all right so
no matter what the challenge it does I
can always make him accept all right so
let's relate this to average his hotness
so let's look at what it looks like in
the in the case of a two round puzzle so
to run puzzle example or answer p1 and
then this verifier is accepting or
rejecting and so so clearly a to run
posit directly implies a horde an
average language in NP because this is a
particular
sampler in samples of random uniform
right and your job is to find a witness
this is a witness right because this is
like an MP relation
so that's trivial another thing that's
triple is if you have some language in
mp that's hot an average for a uniform
distribution meaning that it's hardened
ravage - sample uniform random
statements then that gives rise to
puzzle also right because the sampler
samples random instance that's exactly
the first message that's exactly the
same thing it turns out that actually NP
being hardened average would expect the
uniform distribution this is true if and
only if NP is holding average for any
polymers of distribution there's a
classic result pipe aggressor and living
so combining this objection we have that
tool and puzzles are exactly identical
to the existence of hardened average
language an NP okay and by the same
argument we also get to the existence of
a tool and puzzle with perfect
completeness this implies a hot rabbit
language in teefin P because what does
perfect completeness says no matter what
X you send here there exists a way to
get the guy to answer yes so in
particular for every order exist the p1
a witness so therefore this thing to
impossible perfect completeness gives me
in fact the hardened average language in
Tiffin P alright so the main question
that we're interested in with respect to
these puzzles is you know do they
actually generalize beyond and P alright
we said to run puzzles the basic exactly
is really are the same thing as average
castles in NP but now we're considering
more rounds that it's actually by
momentum or is this kind of the
existence of a puzzle a weaker
assumptions and assuming that the damp
is hot on average so
there had been some results before in
the literature showing this type of
round collapse theorem so you can take
this interactive protocols in collapsed
into something with less rounds in
particular is a very famous round clubs
theorem by Bob a [ __ ] but these round
clubs theorem only work information
theoretically sound protocols and now we
have some that's computationally sound
only the computational hardness to tell
protocol and it turns out that those
kind of results don't actually work at
all they break down yeah so despite the
fact that those results break down what
we show is indeed that the existence of
constant round puzzle turns out to be
equivalent to the existence of hot
average language in NP so constant Ron
puzzles actually don't generalize beyond
empty but if you go to more runs if you
go to Enron puzzles then it does then it
becomes equivalent to the assumption P
space is not in probablistic Paulo Meal
Time so P space is not in P P P so Enron
puzzles is a much weaker assumption
constant run posits or not I'm not going
to really focus on a second result rod
I'm gonna focus on the first one so the
way we prove the first one is that we
actually show that by morons
construction the round collapse
transformation actually works if one a
functions don't exist so if one if
functions don't exist then I can take a
K run puzzle and I can transform it into
K minus one run puzzle while preserving
perfect completeness okay so and if you
hope that you can very easily prove this
thing that a constant run puzzle implies
this by considering two cases either one
a function don't exist in which case you
can take K 2 K minus 1 from Camus and
the K minus 2 and so on and so forth and
get it down to two once you don't it -
you have an average case hard problem
and P if one a functions exists on a
hand then three will you have an average
case hard problem in
in mp which is equivalent to turin
puzzle okay so in either of these cases
we have a two-run puzzle so note that
this is a very kind of non black box way
of doing things because I don't have a
black books transformation from a kaerun
puzzle to RK minus one or a puzzle
instead I'm considering these two walls
of either one in fact it exists or they
don't
yeah okay so let me go into a little bit
of more detail on what this buh-bye
[ __ ] transformation is and and what
makes it hard to prove such such a
transformation in the computational
setting and then maybe I'll mention a
few words on how we can show it assuming
when a function that exists so remember
I would like to have a transformation
that takes a a K run protocol into K
minus one run protocol and I'm going to
focus on three run particles only so I
would like to look at take a three run
protocol and like to collapse it to a
two run protocol and this is above I
[ __ ] and do it yeah they tell the
Challenger so three important goals were
first attacker sends a message then a
challenger sends a message and then I'm
supposed to respond okay now let the
Challenger instead of just picking a
single message he's gonna pick lots of
them okay em messages and random strings
then the attackers job is going to be to
give a single first message and then
responses to all of those things right
so here he started by sending this thing
at first then he gets a challenge and he
supposed to give a response now he has
to give a single first message that
works for all the challenges okay
transformation make sense and then after
and this guy is going to accept if for
all of them indeed he provided an
exacting response so what Bobby Moore in
show and it's a beautiful and elegant
proof I'm going to give it here just for
fun is that if they
the number of petitions is sufficiently
big in particular needs a bigger than
the length of the first message which
might look curious at first in that case
this preserves information theoretic
soundness meaning that if this thing is
information theoretical sound meaning
that there is no attacker that can win
in this thing even an unbundled one then
this thing will also be information to
examine and no attacker can win okay so
let's go over that argument information
theoretic soundness of this protocol
means that for every first message p1 it
is the case that with probability 1/3
over the randomness or here they will
not be an answer right and also
acceptability 1/3 there's no answer with
1/3 you can cheat but acceptable to 1/3
there is no answer ok now if I look at
this thing when I need to provide
answers to all of them what we have is a
very fixed message p1 it is the case
that with the probability over all these
randomness that there exists an answer
to all of them is going to be very very
small in fact except with probability
one minus one more over 3 to the power
of M that doesn't exist are accepting
response to it all of them right because
I need to example this thing now this
message needs to be good for this one
this one this one this one and for each
one hundreds probability 1/3 now the
next thing is he can choose this thing
after seeing them so that seems
problematic but the point is he doesn't
have that many choices of it right so if
the probability for every fixed one is
1/3 to the M that's going to win that is
they can cheat even if it tries goes
over all possible message p1 the
probability exists one
is by the Union Bank to to the you know
the number of possible P ice times that
which is very small okay so what this
says is that if you have some that
information is we take a sound and
everything is great the problem is these
arguments none of them actually work in
the computational setting but and one
thing that's worth pointing out is like
you know the first thing happens is this
is some kind of like parallel partition
when I'm I'm running this protocol many
times in parallel and I'm doing it in
order to make sure there's soundness
error goes down to something very very
small all right and we know for
interactive arguments with computational
soundness we cannot hope to amplify the
sounds to be that small it doesn't go
down to be exponentially small it can go
down to be negligible but not
exponentially small and therefore will
not be able to do any type of arguments
like this not just one reason but in
fact all of these steps cannot fail and
this is not just a failure of the the
proof techniques you can actually come
up with argue come up with puzzles where
if I apply by by moral to them it's not
going to work so here's a very simple
example just to give you some intuition
yeah so here's a 3-run puzzle what I'm
gonna do is in the first run into hash
along that database so it's a huge
database you need to hash it down then
the Challenger is going to ask you is
going to pick a random so here's your
database you hash it down he's going to
pick a random position let's say five
here and the random bit and you win if
you in fact hash down a database that
had that bit there on that random
position okay so for this thing to be a
hard puzzle you need to make sure this
this hash function okay this hash
function needs to be collision resistant
so that when you're sending this you're
locking yourself down to this database
and in that case you know you're gonna
lose the probability one half but you
can win with probably at most 1/2 or 1/2
plus some
to epsilon right you were sending this
thing and he is picking a random
position and asking you please show that
you actually your database had a zero in
this position you know you have no idea
what he's going to say so 1/2 is your
chance of being right now let's see what
what happens if I apply but by more
interesting so in that case the
Challenger here is going to ask me for
lots of different indexes in advance and
I need to hash one database and then
give all downstream openings now the
point here is with high probability he
will not ask for the same index twice at
least if the database is much much
bigger than the hash right so there will
be no repeated indexes here and
therefore I know I just have a bunch of
indexes and what the bit is supposed to
be so I cannot just easily generate this
database and hash it down myself
so it's not just an issue the proof
technique it's just false
Bubba Morin doesn't work but not here
that for this to be hard we needed this
hash function to be collision resistant
so this doesn't contradict what we're
going to prove because we wanted to show
is that if one a function don't exist
then it works ok so the counter example
fails obviously because it relied on the
existence of collision reason hash
functions if one if I still exists you
can find collisions and therefore online
thing wasn't hard yeah so I don't have
time obviously now to go over the proof
for this thing and let me just mention
that it relies on ideas that from
techniques from that we used in the
context of parallel petition and in
particular something called Russ
sampling lemma and that's a lemon that
was used in case of parallel Peters pal
repetition of to prove a games and you
can look in a paper for more details so
let me now just zoom up and finish and
and wrap up so what we done now is we
introduced this kind of generalize a
average-case hardness that we call this
interactive puzzles and the main thing
that we shown was that if one-way
functions don't exist then but by Morris
transformation actually works and that
means we can take a K run puzzle and and
collapse into the K minus R and puzzle
while preserving perfect completeness I
didn't mention it but in fact it's easy
to see that this transformation
preserves perfect completeness also now
we also observe that to run puzzles are
equivalent to MP been--had an average
and TF MP is implied by the existence of
a tour and positive perfect completeness
so now we're going to wrap everything up
by in fact as I mentioned there exists
an early result that we can use cast in
our language and that says you can take
a to run puzzle and transform it in a
three-room puzzle perfect completeness
so taking it all together gets to the
proof for the main theorem so we start
off with NP being harden average that's
the same as the existence of a tauren
puzzle we can take this tool and puzzle
and transform it into a 3-run puzzle has
perfect completeness and if one a
function don't exist we can apply this
babamon transformation and now collapse
it back down to a two-run puzzle that
has perfect completeness so taking this
thing together what we have is that if
endpiece hundred average then T phanpy
is also hot on average if one a function
don't exist and that there forgives our
main theorem that MP being a hardened
average implies either that teefin piece
or average or that one a function exists
any questions on this yeah now back to
your old question now now if you're if
you had proven if it was known that you
can show that when a functions imply
Tiffin P being hot an average combined
with this you would have shown them that
MP being hardened average implies a
Tiffin piece on average yeah so the way
that the proof will go is to say I'm
going to give an instance that I claim
is an EMP instance hard and if you have
attacker that breaks it that attacker
actually is the only function that
secures thing so it's actually kind of
non-black post that way that attacker is
going to be the one in function yeah all
right so let me conclude a so the key
idea that I've kind of used here is to
rely on techniques from literature and
interactive proofs and interactive
arguments to kind of initiate this study
or what we call this interactive puzzles
and these puzzles as I hope to have
convinced you of it's a kind of an
elegant way I think to generalize
average case holidays in NP these to run
puzzles really capture exactly whatever
it is ordinances but now I kind of we
have this more yeah well yeah and
generalization of average is always MP
now once we go to this interaction it
turns out that now we have this whole
tool sets and that's already been
developed for the case of interactive
proofs interactive arguments that we can
rely on and in particular that's what we
did we relied on several techniques
developed for interactive protocols in
order to explore average Cazalas
for sometimes not interactive at all in
fact mujhey with just with an MP but go
they're relied on like taking us to this
interactive real so in the part in the
paper we also consider some consequences
more cryptographic consequences of his
run clubs therefore Interactive
arguments you can read in the paper but
that's more kind of a classic style
theorem but I think this is the more
intriguing aspect that go into
interaction is also helpful for studying
average case hobbies with in NP and
that's it thank you yeah so in fact many
cryptographic assumptions even existence
of collisions and hash functions imply a
hard drive responding to the FMP so you
know in particular factoring discrete
log imply average consolidation P